how are you
[Music]
you
oh
i missed the party at your house this
year i'm so bummed but i saw you
chatting up kim kardashian the whole
time so i wasn't missed at all kim
kardashian honestly has been in our
backyard since high school
and i want to tell you she is the same
wonderful person
that she was back then back then okay i
want to tell this is my lucky tie oh
that's the lucky time do you think it
has anything to do with anything
we're all wearing green
green lucky green
lucky green
i've been sharing space with you what a
great i mean you guys are nominated
you're nominated against each other
is going to be great i can't wait
but let me just say
what a wonderful
soothing teacher he plays
he i wish i had a teacher like that in
my life come on that's from that's from
the fonz man henry that's from a human
being to a human being and that's what's
beautiful about it is the amount of
empathy that you bring to your work to
hear that resonated in you as a person
it fills me man that's that's beautiful
thank you wow it makes me feel good
it's amazing
this is the thing about emmy competition
there's still a lot of love in the
building there is another man his name
is
nick mohammed
okay from ted lasso so it was hard to
sell
hank zipzer to television
we sold it to the bbc yeah
nick mohammed was the principal
of the school i taught at
on the bbc so there are connections oh
and then there's anthony
you know from my from my show anthony
you're going up against your own course
so
i'm just happy to be here with you and
i'm nominated listen it is always a joy
to see feeling very short
[Laughter]
i didn't know this this was a fact i
learned
you are one of the few americans who has
been knighted by the queen
okay i have the the um
the ultimate uh i i have a a
cross
that i that i wear and i'm in a uh of
the realm of the but not a knight
ah so you're of the realm i am yeah but
you still because of the children's
books that i uh took around schools in
england wow when i talked to the
children about uh being dyslexic and how
wonderful they were no matter what their
challenge was
so you had a chance to meet the queen
no you didn't get a chance to meet her
they sent it to me in the mail
no yes i have a big certificate signed
by elizabeth
but i was doing a movie at that time
called here comes the boom yeah and i
couldn't go and receive
the
the order of the british empire is what
it's called wow yeah the obe yeah obe
yeah
all right meanwhile we're back here
again you're nominated again
and
i mean barry is the gift that just keeps
on giving isn't it true
it doesn't not just the nomination
the character i get to play
now i'm rehearsing at home
let's imagine i know my lines and i'm in
baltimore
i'm going to the set
bill then starts directing and takes me
from baltimore
to peru
i had no idea what he was talking about
was in what i thought i knew
wow
that is a gift that gives giving that
keeps kids
tonight you'll go out there and it's
it's that family-style city like the
golden globes again
i'm going to maybe i'm going to see
people that i want to meet
who do you want to meet because you
always have people you want to meet for
my grandchildren
the people from stranger things
if that cast is here holy moly i have to
take a picture
okay
you get that picture i'll see you
backstage after you win because you're
going to win you're going to win but
hold on connie is connie britton's kind
of fangirling right now over here
hi i'm connie and i'm henry and you know
what wait a minute did you meet my wife
my wife adores you
come on mama come
on how are you i'm wonderful
wow oh wow i'm so excited
so
brilliant in everything that you do
connie
oh you're
i mean honestly you've been an
inspiration to me for my whole life
and i could cry meeting you truly for my
whole life and like you have set the bar
so high and then i continue to watch you
just be such an incredible human being
so thank you from all of us that you've
inspired thank you so much and maybe
we'll work together
connie b from your mouth
[Music]